وينضم الينا من واشنطن ازميل بير غانم راس
العربيه مرحبا بكبير هل هناك اي معلومات
جديده حول درجه السريه في هذه الوثائق
المتعلقه ببيض عما تحتوي هذه الوثائق
مضمونها هل من معلومات جديده
ليست هناك ايه تفاصيل ولكن من الواضح ان
الوثائق التي كانت بحوزه بيضا في منزله
وايضا في مكتبه كانت مصنفه على انها اقله
سريه لذلك كانت هناك ضروره من قبل وزاره
العدل للتحقيق في هذا الموضوع لان عمليه
التصنيف سري وسري للغايه همم هي من
المؤشرات الكبيره على انها الامر جدي ويجب
التحقيق في ذلك
بعض من يرى ان وزاره العدل في حرج كبير
الان باعتبار ان هناك اتهامات من
الجمهوريين بانها تتعامل بمستوى مع رئيس
الجمهوريه السابق ترامب واديمقراطيه
الحالي ماذا تتفاعل او كيف تتفاعل الساحه
الامريكيه مع هذا الامر
ما فعله وزير العدل يوم امس كان رفعا لهذا
الحرج بالذات وهو عندما تحدث حول هذه
القضيه واعلن انه يعين محقق خاص في قضيه
الوثائق التي بحوزه الرئيس
قال انه يقوم بواجبه وبالتالي رفع عن نفسه
هذا الحرج لكي لا يقال ان هذا الوزير الذي
تم تعيينه من قبل الرئيس بيضا يحادي
الرئيس على حساب الرئيس السابق ترامب نعم
كيف هي
التفاعلات داخل الكونجرس الامريكيه بعد
سيطره الجمهوريين عليه الان لابد ان البعض
يتوقع ان ثمه اجراء ممكن ان يتم من قبل
الكونجرس الان باعتبار ان هذه فرصه مواتيه
للجمهوريين لانقضاض على رئيس الامريكي
الديمقراطيه
انها بالفعل فرصه ذهبيه وقد عبر اكثر من
رئيس لجنه جمهوري في مجلس النواب على انهم
يريدونها فتح تحقيقات في هذه المساله
بالذات من بينهم رئيس لجنه الاستخبارات
وهنهم يرون الان ان الرئيس بين انه وقع في
الفخ الذي اعتبر ان الرئيس ترامب كان وقع
فيه من قبله وبالتالي الرئيس بيدن في حاله
حرجه كبيره وهو سوف يواجه مع ادارهته
الكثير من المساءلات امام الكونغرس
الامريكي بدون شك ان الجمهوريين يرون ان
هذه فرصه ذهبيه جدا لهم
كيف يلعب انثار ترامب ايضا على هذه النقطه
نجد ان بعض وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه تقوم
باجراء مقابلات وبعض اللقاءات مع انصار
ترامب لاثاره هذه المساله على نطاق
اعلاميين واسع
كل ما يريده انصار ترامب هو ان يقول ان
الرئيس
بيدن تصرف بخبث وبشكل غير عادل اتجاه
الرئيس السابق وربما يكونون على احد في
ذلك والمؤشر الافضل عن الحرج الذي يصيب
اداره بيضا واداره والشخص ايضا الرئيس
ايضا هو انه قبل قليل كانت المتحدثه باسم
البيت الابيض تجري الاجاز الصحفي اليومي
وهي كانت تتهرب من كل الاسئله حول هذه
القضيه الرئيس بيضا يشعر انه في حاله في
حاله السياسي اولا وجرى الجمهوريون هو
مؤيد الرئيس ترامب انهم امام فرصه جيده
للطعم بالرئيس الحالي شكرا لك يا زميلي
بير غانم عربيه من واشنطن على كل هذه
المعلومات